science cares about you no matter
whether you love science or hate science
as people come to understand the power
of it everyone's going to
[Music]
Care hi Eric thanks for coming down for
the interview we're going to start with
just a very broad general question and
it's what does good science look like
and where where have we gone wrong well
it's odd that you ask me of all people
because I think I'm one of the only
people who would give you the answer
that part of the problem is that we have
too much good science and that in fact
good science and great science are not
exactly the same thing good science is
what we're most familiar with because we
know how to train people in it it has to
do with uh being extremely careful um
not falling for uh artifacts in your
data um making sure that you have high
statistical significance being extremely
modest in your claims and your thought
process it's extremely important that
there is a core in fact the majority of
science is good good
science what's really disturbing and I
think something that really hasn't been
seized upon is that great science is
often very different it's not just good
science turned up to 11 which is my
usual line it's in fact a different
process and it borders on the
irresponsible it has to do with crossing
the Adaptive Valley to posit something
that makes no sense to say things that
are in fact wrong for a period of time
before they're right and perhaps the
only two really accomplished uh
scientists who written on this topic
with which I'm familiar might be dck who
wrote about it in 1963 in Scientific
American an article that needs to be
read by everyone is widely
misinterpreted saying that beauty is
more important than agreement with
experiment and Jim Watson who uh had
rules for succeeding in science and in
fact these are clearly not rules for
good science because he was never a good
scientist he was merely a great one so
so maybe maybe another example um is
someone like Fineman right so the way
the way he behaved the way he toyed with
ideas was I imagine not very popular at
the time not the not the kind of thing
that constituted good science but he's
sort of gone down in history as one of
the century defining physicists right
yes although you have to realize that if
you really understand Fineman he was in
fact not understanding of his own work
he viewed uh much of his work as being a
dippy process for sweeping away
Infinities that had plagued the
equations of quantum Electro Dynamics or
Quantum field Theory and in fact uh it
took Ken Wilson to really say why
Fineman and schwinger and tominaga
techniques uh in fact worked that they
weren't a an Infinity cancelling trick
but rather they were a reflection of
scale and something much deeper which is
the Restriction of one's questions to
the layer or strata at which those
questions do not depend on certain
inaccuracies or distortions every model
has distortions some questions are
dependent upon the distortions that that
layer others are not if you're very
careful you stratify the questions and
the layer of the model and you can work
with a flawed model without getting
flawed answers and so Ken Wilson really
elucidated that Fineman um in fact
didn't follow his own Theory far enough
one of the reasons he failed to predict
the uh Zed not particle uh was that
neutral currents were needed for
renormalization he had introduced
renormalization he said that's not a
good enough reason to predict a particle
and he missed a great opportunity yeah
yeah yeah yeah interesting so the I'm
just thinking about what are the
characteristics um of of the people who
have been great scientists or have done
great science so things like uh
creativity I imagine bravery as well um
self-confidence so these are because
they have to say and do things say again
well with Gregor mle for example we
think he fudged his peod data to be
artificially perfect so so uh in fact
skull duggery deception all sorts of uh
very strange characteristics have crept
into good science drug use in the case
of car Mullis uh believing in dreams in
the case of cul and Benzene so I think
we have to understand that great science
is an entirely different kettle of fish
we're very uncomfortable with it because
how do you teach people it's like verer
Herzog the great film director um made a
point of saying you have to uh lie beg
borrow and steal to make great art and I
think that that this is really
unexplored because we're uncomfortable
transmitting the rules for great science
and we've fallen into stagnation because
of it yeah so let's think then about the
Practical consequences of this
observation so there's something ever so
slightly well there's a tension in the
idea of trying to create an environment
which breeds more great science right
because part of the characterization is
linked to this main body of good science
such that one can strike out from it to
be a great scientist um so how can we
Foster an environment is it just that we
need to be more accepting at those
figures those moments when they come or
is there something positive we can do to
create the possibility this is a great
fear of mine about the UK it's you who
should be teaching us how to do this
because you've been punching above your
weight what you do is you put people
under incredible pressure to show their
competency but once they've actually
revealed themselves to be part of a
naturally self- selecting Elite you
embrace elitism for all of its positives
rather than uh decide that these people
have to be subjected to all the horrors
of normal life and I think that the uh
the Oxbridge system um is in danger of
succumbing to America's current passion
for uh equity and egalitarian outcome
when in fact um what you want to do is
not self- select on Bloodlines but self-
select unability and then allow the
truly extraordinary the eccentricities
of their minds because it's like great
wood has a grain to it and a sculptor
would never impose the figure without
first Consulting the wood as to which
way it wishes to be to be moved and
shaped so this complacency that we we're
worried that perhaps the scientific
Community or perhaps the epistemic
community at large is slipping into yeah
um so what exactly is is the danger that
is the danger that there will be missed
opportunities for discoveries for
revolution and Paradigm shifts or or is
there is there a sort of it's far worse
than ethical danger as well I think it's
a tremendous ethical danger but I think
people don't understand it we've LED
people into the valley of death right uh
our previous 20th century Adventures
were so powerful that they're we're
probably not compatible with the
leverage of our discoveries particularly
from the years 1952 and 53 when we
discovered Fusion and the
threedimensional structure of DNA
leading to the genetic code 1963 10
years later that is so much power that
as we've seen with Co and as we've seen
um with the H bombs that have never been
used against humans uh we're probably
not compatible with a single planetary
surface so at the moment you actually
need a Hail Mary and nobody wants to
work on a Hail Mary because it makes us
look non-resectable now if somebody had
said um you know in the 1800s we're
going to have the power of the sun on
the surface of the Earth they would have
sounded like a lunatic on the other hand
now we know that that's entirely doable
so at the moment worry that even over my
lifetime we've learned how not to take
our dreams seriously how not to channel
them into science how not to bring rigor
to our imagination and so we're chasing
people with true imagination out of the
Sciences because what we're saying is is
that that's not good science and by the
way they're it's not incorrect it's
often not good science right and it's
very important not to fetishize good
science because that's Humanity's death
now right so so there's there's there's
also an interesting community
Communications question here right so um
we want to be
fostering uh fostering the kind of
opportunities for great science which
often as you mentioned uh involve soly
irresponsible outlooks um but there is
also a need to be uh communicating with
some areas of society who don't even
understand you know what good science is
um and there seems to be both a both a
kind of need at one level to be creating
great science and another to be
communicating what the point of having
good science was how do you think we can
give those messages simultaneously
you've had Co I have yeah yeah so have I
yeah uh I knew that we both had it and
probably this comes out of science now
whether or not you care about fur and
cleavage sites and whether you care
about amino acids and four of them
strung together and the spike protein
making uh Corona virus virus incredibly
virulent uh your lungs cared about it
your Ace receptors cared about whatnot
so my my feeling about this is science
cares about you no matter whether you
love science or hate science as people
come to understand the power of it
everyone's going to Care Now the problem
is when we disguise the interest in
science and say well how where did this
virus come from did it come from a
Pengalin did it come from a Civic but
instead say any questioning of this
virus in fact is tent himount to racism
well now what you've done is you've
killed the scientific impulse and all
sorts of children you've told told them
that scientists are not powerful enough
to rule their own Roost in fact we are
playing games engaging in skull dugery
so in some sense the tal the sort of
tolerance for bad behavior was spent on
somebody like Anthony fouchy when it
should have been spent on somebody like
a Francis Crick or for in in fact the
person who stopped theide from being a
problem inside of the US was Francis
Kelsey educated at the University of
Chicago to be highly disagreeable and
she simply stood in the way and said I
don't think you've proven to me that
your drug is safe uh would such a person
be tolerated if they said to fizer to
Mna uh I don't think that these
platforms are actually sufficiently
tested and you're asking to undergo a
huge experiment when the virus appears
to be targeting the elderly and obese uh
in fact the problem is is that we've
diminished scientists so far below
administrators that we have to seek
their permission and I think what it's
time for is a scientific revolution in
which we tell the administrators to get
the hell out of our Labs right right so
so am I am I to hear that the um because
I take it that the usual line is that
covid though obviously wreaking havoc
was a great opportunity for boosting
people's interests in science and
boosting some progress on certain
specific areas sure do you realize that
with 12 nucleotides you can shut down
planet Earth and that you have a child
who might have access to PCR and and
maybe chrisper C9 of course you can
interest anybody in science but the
problem is this idea science is
interesting take an interest in science
it's a terrible idea science is
extremely frustrating but it's got very
high leverage yeah we should actually be
truthful about science and we're not
being truthful we're trying to make
science into something that is mildly
interesting yeah and you're you're
signing up people for careers that are
incredibly frustrating uh decreasing in
Prestige uh and in fact one of the few
things you can do with science is shut
down a planet with fair fair ease so so
do you think that um one way to get
across this lesson about the power of
the leverage of science which has been
lost in the communication is doing the
history of science sure but that might
include for example the kid who
scavenged uh smoke detectors for their
radioactive element amorium and built a
working reactor I think in Brooklyn
right right so in other words if you're
going it's like trying to sell
skateboarding skateboarding is an
activity for n duells that sometimes uh
you know results in greatness yeah um
trying to tell people don't take drugs
without mentioning that drugs are fun
you know if we're constantly lying to
people uh there's no opportunity to
actually reacquaint ourselves with the
Wonder of Science and I think that part
of the problem is this idea of
pro-social good for you science is too
narrowly constructed you can get any
child allowed to play with a chemistry
kit where can have potentially dangerous
explosions or you can turn something
into a fountain of Goo you know those
things sell themselves the real problem
is trying to interest people in uh
Dulles Church science that is within
keeping with all of the restrictions
that we're going to place on our
brightest Minds yeah yeah that makes
sense so maybe let's turn to the
biographical now right now we're talking
about how to get people interested in
science what was your first interest in
science how did you begin sure it might
have come from my grandfather who was
probably acknowledged to be the smartest
person in our extended family but who
could not finish University probably had
pretty severe learning issues uh in
modern context and he simply looked at
the world through an extremely
humanistic and very scientific lens and
so just coming to understand that
everything could be open the world was
open source and user serviceable you
could open any panel and try to
understand what made a flower tick or uh
what you were seeing during a meteor
shower so I think that was incredibly
empowering and then I think that um I
made a radical decision not to listen to
my learning differences in school and so
while school was telling me that I was
not very smart uh I just decided that
school was the problem and I was not and
so I followed that path and that battle
probably for me yeah I mean I think one
of the most interesting things I've
learned today is that you're not the
first person to say that to me in these
interviews that's been a running theme
actually well we're actually sort of an
the tiny number of
survivors of the school Wars because
schools try to Stamp Out anyone with the
learning difference and I believe that
these things aren't disabilities but
they're superpowers with negative
externalities and what they do is they
tease out teaching disabilities on the
part of the teaching profession the
teaching profession doesn't want to have
teaching disabilities so they turn
around and create learning disabilities
which are actually non-existent for the
most part right right so one thing that
I think a theme that has been running
through the interview is this idea of um
you know stepping back and allowing
extraordinary people giving them the
resource they need and allowing them to
essentially Express themselves to find
this kind of great scientific moments um
and so it it sort of leads us to this
question about well what what in the
lives of these people is sort of
contributing to that and one one thing I
was thinking was well you know what are
what are the relationship that these
people have to Faith right so I mean
maybe could we could we talk about the
relationship um in in your work between
between how you
see what you do and um whether Judaism
has played a role in that or driven that
in any particular way right so I'm a I'm
I'm an atheist who prays right and you
have to recognize that when you have an
extraordinary contribution of a small
group of people like the parses in India
that there's something in the cultural
practices that leads to an outsized
outcome right and so would it would be
entirely irrational if Jews were to
throw over the irrationality of their
own tradition if that was in fact a
demonstrable scientifically reproducible
Advantage so my belief about this is
that there's something in the ethics the
legal discipline from ttic thinking that
actually grooves the Mind quite well in
particular for physics um I worry that
we've thrown over lots of things that we
now know not to be true but we didn't
understand that these were loadbearing
um behaviors and that effectively we we
knocked out the rotting pillars before
replacing ing them with something else
yeah so I mean when you when you were
thinking about this did you look at a
range of practices and traditions um
because you say you're an atheist at
praise right so you thought you thought
about how these practices are actually
incredibly important for developing the
mind and giving yourself the space to
come up with fantastic ideas and so
forth um you know did you did you look
at a number of different practices with
which to engage as an atheist or was it
simply obvious that Judaism was going to
be I think that I had an intuition that
there was a chomskian preg grammar of
religion and metaphysics right and that
you have a receptor that has to be bound
it cannot remain Unbound so the great
fallacy of atheism is is that it is safe
and adaptive to try to leave the
receptor Unbound because the issue is
that there is some metaphysics that is
going to bind to that receptor whether
or not the truth value of that
metaphysics can be decided yeah uh given
that I found that I happened to be in
possession of one of the more benign
things that could bind that receptor so
just the way it's very it's very
unlikely that you speak no language at
all right and uh you have to probably
address that some way and recognize that
that human need for
metaphysics should Cloud your reason as
little as possible and as much as is
necessary right brilliant well I think
we should wrap it up there thank you
very much thank you really enjoyed it
[Music]